causa pueden creer lo que ven sus ojos
ese es el principal argumento de la
fiscalía en el caso contra derecho ven
para tratar de convencer al jurado de
que el ex policía es culpable de este
caso es exactamente lo que ustedes
piensan cuando lo ven cuando por primera
vez vieron el vídeo pueden creer lo que
ven sus ojos es exactamente lo que creen
es exactamente lo que saben lo que
sienten instintivamente es lo que saben
ahora en su corazón
esto no fue ejercer como policía fue
asesinato la fiscalía argumenta que
george roy murió asfixiado por falta de
oxígeno cuando el entonces policía
derecho bing se arrodilló sobre su
cuello durante nueve minutos como es
posible ver en este vídeo que se hizo
viral e hizo estallar en protestas a
eeuu y al mundo entero en contra de la
violencia policial la defensa sin
embargo quiere descartar ese argumento
asegurando que floyd consumía drogas y
tenía antecedentes de salud
sólo quieren que ignoren los importantes
problemas médicos que el señor floyd
tenía y el fracaso de los expertos del
estado en reconocer cualquier
posibilidad de que esos otros factores
contribuyeron en alguna manera a la
muerte del señor floyd
anyway lo que desafía la ciencia el
sentido común y la razón
sans bajo el temor de que se repita las
protestas del año pasado minneápolis
está en alerta máxima mientras espera el
veredicto en manos de 12 miembros del
jurado que están aislados para deliberar
y que decidirán si condenan o no a
chavín en los tres cargos en su contra
homicidio involuntario homicidio en
segundo y en tercer grado